hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about game thrones season 7 episode
1 and 10 things you might have missed
Easter eggs different callbacks stuff
like that if you have a much upside one
yet this is your spoiler warning it will
give away the major points of that
episode so check out some of my other
Game of Thrones videos instead so
there's a lot of things going on in this
episode as far as setting the table but
there's also a lot of little things that
stand out when you watch it a second
time or a third time anyways number 1 of
10 is the gravedigger I'm getting this
one I was away because it's one of the
most reported and if you've ever read
the books or even just read theories
about the books you probably know about
this one so whenever we saw a cool game
burying those people from the house
everyone said oh look he's a gravedigger
so what happens in the books that's
different about the TV show is in a
feast for crows Brienne is traveling and
she ends up going through the quiet Isle
and she meets someone named the elder
brother here's what's a monastery
basically and he actually tells Brienne
that the Hound is dead and that he
buried him themselves but in that same
sequence there is a mysterious
gravedigger there who's bigger than
Brienne which is something appears to be
lame but he also has this thing wrapped
around his head so you can't tell who he
is so for years that has been the theory
of where the Hound is because he never
comes back in the books or at least he
hasn't yet of course this all opened the
door to the could gain Bowl theory but I
won't get into that right now because we
got other stuff to talk about the second
thing you might have missed was in the
beginning and the intro their Citadel
has been added to the map now that
samwell's taking up residency there and
a lot of this episode is actually spent
there they did add that to the opening
intro and the next thing is also a
change and this change was in the throne
room and King's Landing the
seven-pointed star of the faith was
behind the iron throne but when we see
it now we see the
Lannister lion is in its place I watch
this on the wall had posted photos that
came off a Twitter a long time ago that
so a lot of us had steam that already I
put that one of my old spoilers videos
but if you hadn't been following that
stuff that's pretty cool that that
popped out or if you didn't see it check
it out for sure the next one is about
the Ed Sheeran cameo which I'm sure you
might have heard this one too because
it's been reported on a lot it's not
about him himself it's about his song in
the Song of Ice and Fire books when
Tyrion his hand of the king he has che
but he doesn't have che in the red keep
as a handmaiden for Santa like he does
in the show he has her hidden off in a
place Varys helps him set it up he has
her hidden off in this place and a
singer there he friends her and he wants
to sing at the world wedding so he has
this plan to blackmail Tyrion he writes
a song about her which is the one that
Ed Sheeran sang it's called hands of
gold and it refers to that chain he had
me in the books of golden hands because
he was the hand that whole part is
something about Tyrion story that I
thought the show kind of missed out on a
little bit it basically works but in the
books when you read the book says he was
a really good hand like he really took
care of things and you kind of missed
that in the show he sort of becomes the
hand and then he's not to hand anymore
so sometimes whenever you think about
well why does he become the hand for
Daenerys or why does Varys help them he
really did actually prove himself to be
good at that in the book the next thing
is some sports shadowing that stood out
to me and I haven't seen a lot of
writing about this but I think it's
interesting
you know because we know John is focused
on the White Walkers but there's a lot
of talk about the wall so I think it's
important that you know we bring that up
the first time we hear about it is Santa
and see you know when they're in
Winterfell she says we have a wall
between us and the White Walkers but
there's nothing between us and Cersei so
her attitude is basically like yeah I
know those guys are up there but they're
not going to be able to get to us
because of the wall
later whenever Samwell is talking to
ever
most say by Jim Broadbent he says the
same thing he says the wall has stood
through it all to Sam well so there is
because of this wall and this wall
working for the last thousand years
there is a false sense of security
that's over Westeros and we can see that
that's probably going to be a problem in
his convincing people to get on board
with his battle now the next thing ties
into that because the mountain also
mentions the wall but he sees this part
where the wall meets the sea which is
the exact description of the castle on
the wall of eastwatch-by-the-sea so this
is a lot of foreshadowing that that wall
is going to not be able to do his job
for much longer my thought process I
don't know what you guys think but yeah
it's also interesting here to note that
you know torment and the wildlings are
being sent out to fortify the castles so
they should be putting some people there
but from what we know about what even
that what we saw just in this episode
about the whites and the White Walkers
and their hordes a handful Castle are
not a handful of wildlings isn't going
to do much good up there to stop them
the next thing is something that stood
out pretty quick most of us look for
this kind of stuff and we noticed that
the blade that's referred to as the
cat's paw was drawn in one of the books
one of the restrictive books that
Samwell was looking at remember this is
the Valyrian steel blade that had a
dragon bone hilt that was used in an
assassination attempt on brands of life
this popped up recently because when the
stark kids were photographed for that
magazine cover Aria had it on her hip so
that of course was a big deal now you
remember that Kaitlyn had gone with the
blade to find out who tried to kill her
son and instead of getting to Ned and
showing it to him first he runs into
Littlefinger and Varys and Littlefinger
basically pointed towards Terry and he
said that he they had bet on a
tournament Littlefinger that that Jaime
would win the tournament
the story that he came up with was that
Tyrion took Loras or whatever so
whenever Loras unhorsed em tyrion won
the blade now we know this probably
isn't true but that part of it I guess
is kind of immaterial what's exciting to
everyone I would imagine is that it is
probably coming back into the story so
where has it been the book doesn't tell
us where it's been but it does tell us
some more stuff about dragonglass that's
interesting and if nothing else I mean
they had they they purposely put it on
that page right so and they made a
conscious decision to put it on Aria in
the wardrobe part of that photoshoot so
my guess is is that Ned's the firt last
person that we saw who had it in the
show so my guess is that Littlefinger
reacquired it after all that stuff went
down but since the show doesn't
necessarily follow where it's at in the
books I won't even mention or any of
that but yeah it could be anywhere
if Littlefinger has it does them showing
it on the magazine cover mean that Arya
will get it after she kills him that's
definitely something to see your eyes
about or she could pick it up along the
way but yeah a pretty conspicuous view
of it there and that's pretty cool the
eighth thing is also from that book and
this came from the page on the other
side where you couldn't actually see
everything that was written there but
unready those guys did what they do and
they figured it out of well you know all
of what was available there and then
there was a lot of talk about it and it
basically outlines a cure for greyscale
that involves dragonglass we see in
episode 1 that drawers and a sort of
quarantine in my recap and review I
mentioned that we do know that greyscale
can be cured because Shireen has been
cured but this isn't something that the
citadel usually does so quarantine is
basically what happens you know we've
seen also the stone men out at valaria
old you know oval area but yeah they
don't go around curing people other
greyscale generally
so Sam's reading through this book for
something else and it looks like he
found out that dragonglass can be a cure
for greyscale which you don't have to be
a genius to think that this is probably
what's going to happen is that he's
going to cure him
now there's interesting questions
related to that since the Citadel don't
do that well anybody want to help him
with this
probably not will he have to go and do
it behind their backs probably and you
know it's interesting because it says
something about ingesting the
dragonglass in the actual book so we'll
see how that all goes down either way
being a good study I'm sure Samwell
picked it up and that's going to come in
handy once he realizes that he wants to
befriend this guy Jorah the nice thing
is a callback to the show itself there's
that theme where John and Sons are
walking and she says something and then
brings up the word but you know she says
something good and then she says but and
he points out that Ned used to always
say everything before but it's horseshit
well we've actually seen that before but
seems familiar it's because it was
benjin had said this before he said my
brother used to say everything before
the but doesn't matter so there's an
interesting little callback there don't
think it goes much further but Ned's
words have popped up before and now John
is falling them again and the tenth and
final thing you might have missed is
that Arya has basically completed the
Lady Stoneheart mission what I mean by
that I mean that for years now people
keep hoping against hope that Lady
Stoneheart will show up in Game of
Thrones because she's obviously an
interesting character in the book this
is despite the fact that george RR
martin has directly said that dan and
Dave have removed Lady Stoneheart from
the series and more recently he said
that was one of the things that he that
bothered him about it but still anytime
there's a chance people jump on the idea
that oh they're finally going to listen
and bring Stoneheart in so now that we
know there's not much time left it's
really unlikely but this actually closes
the door on that theory completely the
last we saw her that's what Lady
Stoneheart
doing she was traveling around with the
Brotherhood without banners and she was
punishing people connected with the red
wedding by killing them so by wiping out
all of the significant phrase Aria has
shut the door on their family and on
that theory all right so that's it let
me know if you guys caught all of these
things
did you catch some different ones that
you think I should have put in here did
you catch them on the first watch or the
ReWalk some of these I caught right away
obviously but a couple other ones were a
little bit more hidden I guess you could
say please like this video if you
enjoyed it check out my playlist of Game
of Thrones videos I've got a bunch
please subscribe to my channel I'll be
doing regular Game of Thrones videos
throughout the season follow me on
social media and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon